[Music]
when you step inside this mosque this is
the first thing you see empty coffins
waiting for those who succumb to the
coronavirus this is normally a prayer
Hall
it's normally filled with worshippers
but there's nothing normal about what
this mosque is having to deal with we on
average do between 20 and 25 funerals a
year we've been averaging that many a
week since this crisis began they've
been overwhelmed here 40 volunteers have
rallied together to deliver this vital
service - Birmingham's Muslim community
it's heartbreaking we never imagined
that our mosque would have to run this
service we've never imagined this car
park would have been turned into an area
where Kovac patients are lying there
usually are bid works as an optometrist
but the sheer number of deaths in this
city means he's preparing the dead for
funerals risking his life seven days a
week it's been difficult but we've had
you've had to detach yourself from it
from under on a person on an emotional
level you do have to attach yourself and
treat it as a job there's things that
we've seen the things that we've had to
do that we wouldn't be able to discuss
with people beyond that circle because
they wouldn't really understand and so
we've been our own little support
network and that's really how we've got
through this this is now a familiar
routine whether it's to collect the dead
from homes or hospitals or whether it's
taking them to the cemetery to be buried
every volunteer needs to be fully
protected
right now they're taking a body for
another funeral another life lost to
Kovac 19th
this mosques carpark is now a temporary
more tree it's taken up by a 40-foot
container inside it can store up to 30
bodies they have no idea how long it
will have to be here I guess you would
never imagine you'd see something like
this hidden in this mosque
never in my lifetime I speak to my dad
and like parramatta mom and dad and
aunts and uncles and they said never in
their lifetime would there ever have
thought that this would have happened
here in the UK or any way in the world
I've been to a number of mosques right
across the world and especially here in
the UK but never sense this sort of
atmosphere it's chilling it's quite
sobering and especially when you see
coffins like that stacked up inside a
prayer hall it's a real reminder of the
grim reality of this pandemic preparing
for death is as part of Islam as any
religion but it's people power alongside
faith that keeps this community spirits
alive in spite of the task they face in
summer she'd Sky News